okay let's talk about sabine
hostenfelder
who says that the idea of free will is
both incompatible with the laws of
nature and entirely meaningless okay
what are your thoughts on that statement
yeah so i i know sabine
and i use actually so so she does a lot
of these videos
and i love most of them
now she has one indeed on freewheel
and actually i use that one when i give
some of my lectures
to um to illustrate how extreme some
physicists
including very good physicists
can become and indeed in this
video sabine goes really a very long way
and you know claiming that if you
believe in free will you are denying
signs
so she is really claiming that actually
science has answered the question in the
negative there is no free will and this
is in my opinion a clear
overstatement it's it's taking physics
as a religion somehow
and it's physics with classical
mathematics again we just discussed that
[Music]
and it's pretty strange that uh
sabinofenfelder makes that kind of
mistake because one of
her book
which i like very much i think it's
called lost in mathematics
actually
yeah says we have to be careful we the
physicists have to be careful not to
overestimate
mathematics
you know in high energy physics
people try to uh
to guess the future theories just by the
beauty of mathematics by symmetries and
elegance and things like that
and um
[Music]
so she says no but maybe actually the
the the correct mathematics of the next
uh
physics uh theory will not be as elegant
as we
think or would like it to be
so okay that's a reasonable argument and
i certainly buy that argument but then
herself
takes classical platonistic mathematics
of the truth and because platonistic
mathematics considers only
objects mathematical objects that are
outside of time
it's a timeless language classical
mathematics and so when she concludes
that time cannot exist and that
everything has already to be settled so
she also believes strongly
uh in super determinism
you know everything is already
determined there is no quantum
randomness
inequality violations can be explained
by
super determinism
and
yeah at least she's very consistent that
uh certainly grant her
but when
when she claims that science has proved
it for instance
that free will is an illusion
she goes too far
and she goes too far by taking
mathematics too uh
literally can you quickly outline to the
audience what super determinism is
perhaps what you dislike about it
yeah well actually there are two things
that i dislike so firstly is already
determinism let me come back to that but
so you know the entire future like the
entire past everything is already
determined doesn't mean that we know it
or it doesn't even mean that we have any
ability to
get that knowledge
but you know
ontologically fundamentally it is
already determined that's determinism
now when people say
super determinism
they add an extra little assumption
namely that
um
okay it's that everything is coordinated
because you could still imagine that you
know this part of the universe is
entirely determined
that part is also entirely determined
but they are not yet connected so we are
still independent systems that exist in
the world
now if you i if you also reject the
existence of in
independent systems
then this is
super determinism some other people
would probably
say that super the super of super
determinism means
a kind of conspiracy because when these
these different things not only needs to
be already
connected so not
independent but they have to be not
independent in a very specific way for
instance to explain the violation or the
apparent violation of bell inequality so
i certainly dislike completely the idea
that there exists no independent systems
in the universe
and actually my my view is
very clearly i mean physics has to be
able to tell stories physics should make
predictions we all know that and
predictions of course should agree with
the experiments
but physics is not only about
[Music]
sophisticated theories physics is also
about telling a story
you know when you go to a class or if
you teach or i did a lot
you never start by writing an equation
you start by telling a story
and for instance everyone knows
most people know that the tides are due
to the moon that attracts the water from
the ocean and so on and so on and you
don't need an equation for that story so
the stories are super important
in science in general and also in in
physics
but there are no stories without
time
you need to be telling something in time
an event takes place in time that the
moon attracts this water is something
that takes place in time if you remove
the time
there is no story any longer
and how does time come in for me time is
very very much connected
to the actualization of
potentialities as aristotle would have
said you know to the fact that this new
information created
during the the course of time
so it has to do with indeterminism
and now so that already explains you why
i think if
with just deterministic stories
i don't think we can really tell how
nature does it